bello a tutti ragazzi e benvenuti a
questo video vi presento samp è un
barboncino poi toy story sembra un
giocattolo ma non lo è
allora io non ho mai avuto un animale
domestico è tutta la mia vita tranne i
pesci nell'acquario e allora dopo un
sacco di mappa più non so quante
ricerche sono riuscito a trovare questo
lupo da caccia che aveva bisogno di una
casetta e allora glielo trovata io ci
hai voglia di fare blog
vabbè tanto facciamo questo è il primo
giorno in cui sono andato a prenderlo
[Musica]
quando è entrato in casa ho dovuto
presentarlo ai mobili
[Musica]
una volta arrivato a casa
nel tragitto ancora non avevo deciso
come chiamarlo nel tragitto ho deciso di
chiamarlo some time e il cane di will
smith in io sono leggenda chiama samp
perché la briga tivo di samantha solo
che lui è un maschio e cioè cioè il
pisellino quindi non si può chiamare
samantha si chiama same basta tipo sfera
mou sindoni casarotto la qualcosa come i
cuccioli dormi bene
sembri un peluche zio fatto vedere come
fai essere così piccolo perché mi segue
ovunque come i pokémon pp
no bagno pv si cucina ip no facce della
carta no non pestare schifo schifo
enders no kakà in bagno dove la cacca
bravo 2000 caccia sono creature molto
pericoloso per il semplice fatto che i
loro denti potrebbero tirar via la carne
in un nanosecondo
la felpa mi rovini la felpa per cui ci
hanno pagato a 29 euro sono un povero ho
tolto il cartellino così non seguiamo
povertà
[Musica]
però la cuccia non è servita una sega
perché di notte ha dormito con me è
stata non ho dormito niente in realtà è
stato casey mi dormiva in faccia
praticamente l'altro penso di avere il
cane più intelligente del pianeta perché
a tipo un giorno di vita un altro po e h
gato nel pannolino
com'è possibile come è possibile che sia
più intelligente di me ed è nato ieri
bravo ma bra brawn e questo è quello che
gli scienziati chiamano autocannibalismo
diamo fondo a queste ricerche sull auto
cannibalismo prossimamente sul mio
canale posto il mio canile non avere un
cane veramente ukaze i batteri elevato
il tappeto sono sinti raffia va tutto lì
il tappeto il pesce è diventato un
optional
perché se pisciano solo piangere chi
deve aprire e fammi fare la cacca poi
salire sul divano e mi sa che ti sbagli
ma che poi fa gol
va bene che sia casa mia se mi cadi sul
divano io che faccio un brutto il divano
anche registrare i video è diventata una
cosa molto difficile però in qualche
modo faremo
[Musica]
scemo non ha pistrice c'è lo spiraglio a
mongoloide qua qua vada ad onna un genio
in tutto questo mia mamma non sapeva che
avessi preso un cane l'ho ripreso la
reaction di mia madre che entra in casa
che vede the sun
per la prima volta niente quindi dalle
sue avanti io avrò un cane tristi sì
adesso mi vado a lavare tutto vero che
vi sia piaciuto ragazzi questa è la sum
come se mi è piaciuto commento e mi
piace anche per i soci al covino dalla
descrizione senza doversi richiedere lo
scegliamo hai visto che adesso tutte le
cagne vengono da te perché sei famoso